fighting this is not you discharging a
weapon at enemy here
this is you observing what is going
going on yeah that's me just having a
quick butcher's at the kitten equipment
that they've been issued so
young soldier come to me have a bushes
like this i have a look at it and that's
what happens
right the main thing is you came back
and you reported in its present form
this war against is is unwinnable yeah
i believe it is on winneball the moment
unless we do something a bit more than
what we're doing the airstrikes alone
are not enough to win a war like this
some say somebody's got to get in the
weeds
and get messy yeah why is that filled
because i mean the general consensus
among politicians
you will hear very very few politicians
saying get involved get boots on the
ground
they won't say that because you know
obviously nobody wants to lose any more
troops
and unfortunately this is a messy
business you know and if you look back
at any conflict you know
the the americans lob stuff in the
vietnam views and they just went
underground didn't they and this will
happen there they'll change their
tactics and they'll adapt to what we're
doing to them
so you've got to get in there you've got
to get hold of them and you've got to
say right off you go because we've got
enough of it
let me ask you why did you get in there
why did you put your
your life on your line you've served
your time you've done your bit
for queen and country why put yourself
in the firing line
again for this what is what is your role
in all of this
i wanted to report back from there
exactly what was happening
and i think you know the normal
correspondent with the with the blue
flat jacket the press on the front and
the helm on lopsided running around with
pressed clothes
ain't gonna do that i'll do that i'll go
in there because that's my environment
that's what i've learned to do over
quite a long career
and so you know the picture i'll give
you back would be slightly different
to what to what a normal correspondent
would give you so what's the program
actually going to show us about what's
going on on the ground with iso the
program will show you my journey
along the front line which stretches you
know through syria from up by al hassaka
all the way down to cook
we went in the end and it will show you
the guys and girls that are fighting
and some would argue on our behalf and
keeping that front line between isis and
the rest of the world
now you say they're the guys and the
girls yeah this is the ypg these are the
female fighters
why are they so important
important because they they all
everything together every fighter down
there is important to be honest i mean
but ias particularly do not want to be
shot in
there they don't want to be shot injured
or killed by a female because they
believe that you know they then lose
their virgins and their paradise and all
the rest of the stuff that they've been
promised
you know one once they've been in while
they've been indoctrinated into what
they're doing
yeah and this is the role the women have
to play let's have a look at this
this is my personal opinion i swear no
one has told me to say this
women fight the same as men maybe even
better but now we're all fighting for
the same cause
we fight as equals i say that women can
never be superior to men
and vice versa yet some fight just like
men
maybe even better well we saw you
testifying the equipment there
tell me about the the equipment and what
the soldiers how well
or not they are equipped right they're
not well equipped
they've got old russian gear that's been
cannibalized that's been picked off the
enemy um they've got a limited supply of
of ammunition and bombs and that sort of
stuff
and they're up against a force that
basically have taken their weapon and
gear from an
iraqi army who's capitulated once being
fully equipped and decked out by the
americans with all the latest gear
so it's not it's not massively fair on
the equipment side of life for them
phil i just want to put this to you
we've had the wording on the news wise
from syrian curtis militia who say that
they're going to launch an offensive
and racker against is and they're saying
that
basically they're working a bit better
operationally on the ground than perhaps
you're suggesting this is a
this is from syria the kurdish militia
so that they're about to launch an
offensive on
uh is targets in raqqa and they're
saying they're actually making good
progress on the ground
from what you've seen when you were
there do you understand that to be the
case you think they're making the
headway that they're saying
they can against certain targets if
they've got enough people and enough
gear behind them
you know it's not for the want of
fighting these people because they're
absolutely game as you like they're
write up for it you know so it's not for
the want of that
where it's lacking is is a very long
front line and so
you know it's it in some places it's not
as well equipped as others so they're
winning
they might be winning the small battles
in one area but then you know they're
going to have to hold firm in another
what i don't understand
is surely if you do send in fighter
planes and they bomb
and they blow the opposition to pits
surely that has got to be a big thing
why do you say that's not
effective enough it's a big thing yes
and don't don't get me wrong they
appreciate it
but like i say i is will adapt to that
and they'll go underground that's not
killing everybody and you've still got
luna loads of rubble and loads of towns
and loads of things
okay so what's the answer to that if
it's not exactly
a full-scale infantry on the ground
special forces
possibly you know i'm not gonna voice my
opinion on special forces on television
i'm not really allowed to comment on
that you know what their role would be
but certainly somebody once it's been
softened up needs to go in there and
pick through the pieces
or it's not going to finish it or just
they'll just regroup and come back
regroup
but what i'm saying could this be one
with a combination of air strikes and
special forces
yeah with all the bells and whistles
deployed yeah yeah we'll have we'll have
a popper that well and i think
would we've room to be honest but it
needs it needs all the bells and
whistles deployed
you can't talk like i would do a bit of
that and put it out in a bit of this it
don't happen does it
anybody watching big phil's war tonight
what will they come away with what
impression will they come away
they'll come away with you know what i
saw you know i've gone down there to
report on how the soldiers see it and
exactly what it's like on the front line
i had to get myself into a bit of a
punch-up to do it but you know i think
it was worth it i hope it was worth it
okay we'll find out it is on sky
atlantic it is 10 o'clock tonight
and also nine o'clock tomorrow night on
sky news phil
thank you very much